Paulie goes you know Reggie Miller is
such a nice guy and then he steps on the
court for a tree point an improv
three-point shooting contest and all of
a sudden the old Reggie Miller came out
there man look good well look I was fine
this is almost like like The Godfather
you know once you were out then they
just yeah I could take this old man down
in a shooting contest Jill the last
thing to ever lose did you ever leave a
ballplayer is his shooting I mean I was
trying to give him an opportunity but I
don't know if he was nervous or well
he's a player for Texas San Antonio so
Dan we got the big man Kendall and Gio
from UTSA Roadrunners come down brought
out all the smack talk I've never seen
anything like that once he started goes
I'm up 1-nothing I'm up to nothing for
nothing I went this isn't good
and you know this poor kid comes rolls
out of bed comes over here and he went
to bed in that uniform ready for you he
just came from the club you didn't play
with guys or play against guys who did
that did you came straight from the club
yeah come on as the NBA of course just
rolled in put on their shoes and let's
go could you ever see like Club stamps
on a guy's hand
yes the VIP entrance yes full
introduction
regi proving once again and he doesn't
have to one of the greatest shooters
ever Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA and
NC double-a analyst he's got the third
Thunder Spurs coming up tonight on TNT
and of course the Final Four and the
national championship can be seen
exclusively on TBS and also team cast
presentations on TNT and truTV good to
see you man guys for having me I do
consider myself the honorary fifth Dan
there so it's always good to be with my
brothers in person I know we always do
this conversation you know when I'm in
California but it's good to actually see
you guys and have fun with you guys
well we got nominated for Sports I mean
congratulations and you were the best so
you'll get if we win you win when when
we win yeah I'm doing the Larry Bird
three-point shooting yes like we win
this really yeah she I'm giving you a
Sports Emmy you get my snot on yours you
well you have like 25 a few of them
about 25 sort of feel like Bill Russell
with Championships there you know it's
not fair look like someone rolled out of
bed with a little modesty this morning
if we win you win because you're the
word team work well off one another and
people did say you know you call them
the dinettes that means they're women
and I go and you're the one that came up
with dance because I'm gonna guess
Michael in the Jordanaires exactly okay
so a lot of that because I mean we are
all loyal followers of you so we're like
your Supremes we're the supreme I like
that right yeah no but that's you came
up with the name the nickname for these
guys and then I have this duck though
had to be the fifth one all right what
do you want to talk about well number
one LaMarcus Aldridge
I really hope
settle down LaMarcus please play tonight
I know he's questionable within the
injury San Antonio is scratching and
clawing to get their way not only into
the playoffs but they've got to go seven
and OH - I believe it's a ridiculous
what like 17 or 18 straight 50 wins or
something like that yeah
so that won't happen they won't go seven
- no but I want LaMarcus to get better
so he can play tonight it's a huge game
versus Russell Westbrook and the OKC
Thunder or positioning in the Western
Conference though I want to see a great
game tonight with LaMarcus it would be
nice if Kawhi would make a cameo I mean
ice what is going on I dunno I I really
wish I could put a finger on what is
going on here this has always been a
great organization pop is fantastic you
know quiet all I've ever heard a little
interview we'd never had him on ever
ever no I know him a little bit just
because he's from the IE Riverside and
I've had a chance to talk to him a
little bit but I can't put a pulse on
what's going on I don't know I don't
know if it's the injury I don't know if
there is bad I don't know I really don't
know
I mean I'll probably get a better sense
when I get over to the arena and I get a
chance to talk to some people but we're
talking about one of the top five
players in our game that's miss Dana do
you think he's here next year uh that's
a no if I got to think that long I will
say no I hope not
because this this has been a stable
organization with superstars you hope
that he doesn't leave hope he doesn't
yeah yeah he's a great face for San
Antonio
I hope he doesn't leave but there's a
lot of sharks in the water weight and
yours they're chumming this up the out
west was you know there's a team you
know that is in desperation of a face
but do you think the Lakers like if they
whiff in the offseason like how big how
important is this hope they don't get
LeBron
and or Paul George Kauai I think it's
gonna be their number one target does he
feel like Los Angeles I know you know
it's one thing to be from there but he
still feels like San Antonio where you
know they're stars or you know they
they're kind of not a non-anonymous but
you know they're they're quiet they they
don't that's his demeanor yes and really
that's his game other than when he goes
crazy on the defensive end
I want Kawhi Leonard to be a lifetime
spur that's what I want I want to see
that I want I love when your best
players are in small markets I loves
LeBron James in Cleveland that's why I
was so disappointed when you went to
Miami you've got to have a balance of
power you know la Chicago New York
Boston the big markets they always get
the talent because people feel that's
where your endorsements come in today's
age of social media you don't need to be
in a big market to be a superstar so
when you have the MVP Russell Westbrook
in OKC
I like that I think that's what's great
about football and Aaron Rodgers being
in Green Bay I mean you got to have
superstars
in small markets Kawhi Leonard LaMarcus
Aldridge
Gregg Popovich five championships I love
everything that's about the Spurs I do
Reggie Miller joining us here in San
Antonio karl-anthony towns went off
again last night if I said you could
have karl-anthony towns or Anthony Davis
Anthony Davis okay I'm there too because
he plays defense he's I think he's more
suited to today's and karl-anthony towns
like old school oh he's a he's a
throwback in his size and his athletic
ability in that frame the only knock on
on Davis is the injury bug yeah I mean
can you stay healthy for a full season
but in terms of footwork shooting the
basketball play with this back to the
basket karl-anthony towns I mean how
great is the center position and I
really don't consider Anthony Davis a
sinner I think he's more of a power
forward but you've got the Joker Joe
kitch from Denver Joelle and bead I mean
the
Center position which everyone's saying
is a dinosaur now yeah I think it's
starting to come back a little bit now
those guys are gifted where they can all
knock down threes and play outside the
paint but the center position is looking
pretty good in the NBA and he put up
with 56 last night 15 rebounds I think
had five threes nobody's done that in in
35 you said 15 rebounds like 56 and
fifteen yeah I mean but Anthony Davis
has had a couple those kind of games
like a string of like seven or eight in
a row where he had Pumped himself into
that MVP conversation but he's he more
valuable to his team considering what
they've done than James I think James
Harden is gonna win it I think it's
almost like the Academy Awards like it's
your time right and I think that it's
James Harden's time I don't think you
can convince me that he's more valuable
than Anthony Davis I know it's a better
record a better team and a chance to win
a championship Anthony Davis if you
watch the pelicans it's tough to watch
the pelicans especially after your
boogie cut went down yeah though I will
give contributions to Drew holiday who
has played fantastic this year has a
he's resurrected his career there but to
your point this is all about Meryl
Streep should always win the Academy
she's nominated everything a year and
she should win every single year but
that's just not the case I think this
has been James Harden's years since the
new year it went in waves when we first
started in October November it's all
about the Greek freak oh my god well
everybody was trying to shoehorn him in
there the first three weeks he was
unbelievable yeah but he's not
people still say oh you know it
to me it's LeBron and James it's it's
those two I would kind of put Damien no
one's talking about Damien Lillard and
what he's done with Portland over the
last two Mars day Mia Lillard has been
fantastic in Portland I kind of had
DeMar DeRozan in there a little bit for
the success so try I put success of team
that's why I think James Harden will win
it just because he's had he's been the
best player on the best team you have
okay so LeBron said he would vote for
himself I love that I mean in any show
do you ask him a question but he you
want a guy who
yeah has confidence in there's no fake
humility there and he's put up his best
numbers at 34 35 15 is a 14 or 15
is this his 14th year 14th year and he's
putting up these numbers in the
Association playing 36 minutes a game I
mean that's I could almost barely move
in my 14th year but he's he's played a
hundred more games now than Michael
Jordan played in his career yeah he's
already there and he's got four or five
more years and I know it's setting up
the great debate on who is the greatest
and it's different rules different eras
but people need to factor into Olympic
play or LeBron
all-star games I mean these things add
wear and tear on your tree oh yeah
so I mean for him to be playing at this
level for so many years that's it's
remarkable it feels like LeBrons already
won because we're we're bringing him
into the conversation you know but his
game has brought him into the
conversation know he deserves to be in
the conversation it's just there's a
certain age bracket where nobody you're
they're gonna shut you down when you say
you know LeBron is I think LeBrons a
better all-around player than Mike not a
better player better all-around player I
would probably agree with you on that
yes yeah I mean that's not that big a
stretch no okay now here's what I want
to know what do you think Michael Jordan
truly feels about these comparisons or
if somebody brings up LeBron James the
true Michael Jordan well you see what I
did to Geo so you saw how I talked to G
all right yeah I guarantee you it is 20
times worse if you were taught if you
were Michael Jordan and I was I'm like
hey so what'd you think about LeBron
come on man
he was absolutely wood he would treat he
would he would go off yes that's just
the competitor in him he never took a
backseat to anyone hate the dude can't
stand the dude but I can't fault the
dude I can't fault him but but he's not
any different on the court than he is
off the court is he he's a shrewd
businessman
oh yeah he's a billionaire for a reason
you never asked you to go into business
with absolutely not he never asked me to
wear Jordans Thanks
he didn't want to see that tongue
looking right back at it when I was
going by oh would you have worn the
Jordans I did wear the Jordan oh I did
wear the Jordans oh I didn't know that
yeah towards the end of his career and
when he went to Washington now he kind
of started to form Jordan Brand and it
was not and it wasn't Mike that asked me
it was a person that knows the person
that knows the person that asked me to
wear Jordan bread Mike would never ask
me to wear Jordan Brand just did he say
anything when you saw you wearing him
maybe nice shoes shoes I'll tell you if
he walked in here right now G me and geo
versus Scotty and what's what's thirty
ones named Kim down Cadell so you you
and geo against Mike and Wow you go make
a shot by passing the ball can you make
a wide open shot G oh geez oh no you
can't know you ain't guardin my zero
[Music]
then let the heavy lift it over here all
right
Gio's regretting to fly with the Eagles
you get your rest
did you Ray whoa you gonna come from the
king you better come heavy alright
alright yeah you're just like chilling
that night he's on the ferris wheel all
night just chilling oh I'm gonna go
shoot Reggie Miller
Oh me nagging okay all right and you
were talking about Jordan being a jerk
on the car that's how Michael Jordan
used to talk to me now as little
questions as I'm talking now
MJ used to gave this to me yes
so imagine that did he ever say anything
nice to you no no y'all bringing up
memories I'm not ready to really snap
and what's the story you haven't told
about the last show the last show your
last show I tell you what when we win
our Emmy and that next Monday when we do
a show all right okay yeah so that's
second week in May what if we don't win
the M you will never hear that story
what's the story we'll hear if hear like
a nice g-rated okay you know Magic
Johnson the Jordan story how about if
Loyola wins the title you can hear it
okay I want to win yeah I want lower
little win yeah I think they have that
who's your type bill to this tournament
I want Loyola to win who do I think will
win last time I was on your show yeah in
person yeah I picked Villanova cuz no
one was taking them in that Final Four
at that particular time in the end of
when AJ right I think and Jalen Brunson
has those guys locked in I'm going with
Villanova to win it they will win it but
I want Lowell I just want that small I
like small town guys I like when the
underdog has a shot to win a new purse
is the big boys right it's not what we
want in America yeah who was in the
Final Four in fact let's take
great can we take a break let's take a
break now during the live look in if
you're watching on TV I want you to show
me what James Harden does and how he
gets away with things you got it okay
you mean the there's there's a couple
things he does and he's never called on
it okay I want to know I want to know
the secrets of this you got it all right
no problem the dance will play defense
on reg yes what do you want us to guard
the river walk these Geo might be taking
[Music]
can't hit the ocean but he might geo vs.
McLovin coming up next you know when
somebody talks about your jumper being
wet it's usually that you're making
shots the Geo
it could be wet going into the Riverwalk
we'll take a break more with Reggie
Miller right after this in the Dan
Patrick show yeah okay you ready here we
go you got this come on G okay let's go
[Applause]
I want to show you what when I play pick
up poop this is how it looks like h&L
are putting on a a shooting clinic and
then McLovin started to put on a
shooting clinic now I know why Texas San
Antonio didn't make the tournament some
other players are here you know yeah 20
or 15 that's not bad that's not bad poor
cheating on your conference who won your
conference oh okay
you scored nine points a game by the way
he's legit did not score nine for the
game so reg was putting on a little bit
of a clinic we're giving away tickets
down here and then McLovin wanted a
piece of Geo who plays for the
Roadrunners I was waiting for fritzy to
want a piece of it we're saving the
hookshot yeah but we do have our first
person yeah we're shot next break we're
gonna are you ready wait tickets we're
gonna at least try to do some
bring jacks push-ups do something stay
warm do you who was the final for your
senior year well you went to the
tournament once once my senior year we
lost you finis Timbo that the big guy
Eric yeah in it weird that you can
there's certain players that you just
remember the names Venus Timbo
we got him drafted that game got him
drafted in the first round
what was it about cuz I didn't think he
I thought he was a scorer I didn't think
he was a great shooter but it was just
what they were on he was a good
all-around player they had a solid big
man in Eric but Fitness Timbo put on and
absolutely shooting clinic versus us and
as they always say you never
underestimate your opponent and you
never want to look ahead personally we
were looking ahead I will say I was
looking ahead because I was the best
part of team because if we would have
beat Wyoming we would have faced up
versus UNLV and we never you know you
know V at the time because that was you
know V who was under coach Tarkanian
they had those great teams and UCLA and
UNLV never wanted to play one another
because they were in recruiting battles
so we were like okay finally we get to
play unis wasn't Larry Johnson station
know you had an arm and Gilliam arm and
Gillian yes yes okay because the one
with Stacey and Larry they were good
that was they were said that was there
they weren't against Duke and grin and
Laettner and who do you think was more
impactful that UNLV team or the Fab five
culturally Oh culturally the fire okay
they change college bass it was a better
team well you know the one what one or
two chaps a one woman and then lost they
won the championship so you had to go
the team that actually wanted okay but
that didn't mean they're better
they were just better than Oh Greg
Anthony grandmomma Larry Johnson Stacey
Augmon that was if they were they were
pretty good anderson hunt understand
hunt a shooter yes yeah but they play
defense like when you think of everybody
thought it was running
Runnin Rebels but what torque did get
them to do is they play great didn't
mean Augmon was a great defender but we
can't put what michigan did with by
freshmen yeah to reach back-to-back
Final Fours i don't think will almost
never be done again I mean I think
Kentucky came close when they wanted
that young one year where they all
freshmen when they want it under Coach K
with uh the brow oh we've got Calipari I
don't I don't work all from no right no
but it's still pretty amazing that you
had five freshmen and they had attitude
that swag swagg the baggy the black
socks but do you think that J it felt
like it was Jalen roses team if Webber
was the star but Rose sort of gave them
that attitude I would probably agree
with you on that because Webb Weber
doesn't seem like he's that I mean I
think that he fed off it's almost like
Kareem fed off magic a little bit there
you know magic got him excited and it
feels like Weber did a little fun Dini
Brown any round yes yes I wanted you to
explain this if you can what James
Harden does cuz I show this to the Dan
Nets all the time where I go wait James
Harden doesn't look like he's doing
anything but he gets around everybody he
scores
whenever he wants to well he is
deceptively quick which people don't
think when you look at his body you
think maybe a little putt he doesn't
he's not pudgy but you think he's a
little bit overweight he has the
strength because his forearms are so
strong he lowers his shoulder every
single time he gets either a step with
you or a step ahead of you and once you
try to close on him he's putting his
shoulder he's the one that's initiating
I would say with McLovin if if you're
watching so I mean reg is still
explaining it though you know if you're
on listening on radio but because so
look most of the time when when James is
go this way since he's left-handed so
you're playing in front of him once he
starts like this and you close the gap
his point is I want you your body to get
on my body he wants to feel you most
great scorers in the NBA they need
contact people think oh my god I need to
create space to get my shot off James
Harden wants you to have contact on them
because that way he can feel you then he
can create to write once in once he
knows the shot he wants that's when he
travels which they never called and he
shoots the threes so I want to create
that space and then you know I'm shoot
to shine so now a lot of times when he's
in the lane and while he gets fouled all
the time a former player of mine
debtless shrimp used to do this all the
time bring the ball down and try to
swipe see how I changed it the laughing
so I'm going up and that's how he gets
the call every single time because when
you come down the swiping you think
you're gonna get it so you're going up
how would you draw these fake found dirt
Novitsky be able to get away with that
extended foot way with the knee right
into your midsection he be able to do
that Oh reg should okay it's harden you
know we always talk about somebody's
unstoppable it feels like Harden is
getting into that short kill O'Neal
being and Michael Jordan who else was
unstoppable
Michael Shaq wilt and before they
outlawed the crossover and they really
changed it back AI because a I carried
yeah
on his crossover until they changed the
rule but I would say those guys had you
could not guard them because it wasn't
fair but they really put a lot of
pressure on the officials because you
could call a foul on every play with
those guys
you know hardens getting it because she
can shoot the three yeah he can drive he
can shoot free-throws and then you have
finishers like Nanae and Clint capela
when the bigs comes up he just throws it
to the rim and that's why he's averaging
10 11 assists a game
what we should like to try to guard
Iverson it wasn't pretty because we had
young AI when we faced him in the
playoffs and that's before they outlawed
it and he took first of all he's not
this big and he was so high on his cross
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he crosses Jordan over and then crisis
him over and Mike almost got a piece of
that yeah but that's Mike had to be
really how low if you could run this
poly when you show that look how low
because when you say Michael almost got
it
look how although Michaels hand is when
he crosses the ball that's how low
everything was on that clock
yeah the ball goes under his hand we
were trying to pick up your sound on
your mic oh sorry
off that microphone there we go sorry
sorry yeah yeah so Reggie Miller joining
us here I don't know what else we need
to cover here that we have
this is great you put on obviously our
games are exclusively for the Final Four
on TBS on Saturday and Monday but
tonight if you want some basketball
action head on over to watch the Spurs
versus the Thunder all right it's gonna
be a great one the reigning MVP
Russell Westbrook we hope the Marcus
Aldridge plays but come on down and
let's have some fun
now mclubbe it's all in on Oklahoma City
and light weight yes I think they're
dangerous but you always do this now it
makes it seem like I'm all in on okay
there are dangerous out in a seven-game
series I'll be during the regular season
I think they've been trying to I know we
keep saying this trying to find
themselves and how is this three-headed
monster really gonna work but once you
get to the playoffs and there's no back
to backs there's really no travel
restrictions they will be a tough out
should I be all in on them maybe this is
a good idea is a tough out and I don't
think you should be able and win the
West but they're a tough out especially
what's going on with they won't be
Golden State but the injuries concerned
me we've talked about this I said in
October hands down Golden State was
gonna win this barring major injury well
we see the major injury bug bite them a
little bit it'll be interesting to go on
to me it's still a two-headed race
between Houston and Golden State but I
sure don't want to see that in the
Western Conference Finals that would be
an unbelievable matchup
are you the all-time leading scorer with
the Pacers what who else would be
well-liked from the ABA days like
Daniels yes yes I am
you're the old time leading scorer yes
all right well congratulations
Doug Gottlieb will stop by Frank Martin
South Carolina head coach Seth Davis
from CBS will stop by as well reg giving
hugs one hour the votes two more to go
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]